me morning are you door hmm exciting
week my friends this week was kind of a
big deal for me and you want to know why
my parents came down to see me now my
parents is I moved out I haven't visited
me once and that's just based on the
fact that they don't love me no in all
honesty it's not because they didn't
want to is because they didn't have the
luxury to favorite running a beauty
supply store for the past 26 years now
and you guys know that when you own your
own business you guys can't step away
from it whenever you guys want to it
doesn't really work out that way
and me being a Korean child you guys
know when I go back home know the first
thing I'm gonna do yeah yeah not
actually stick to my goals I don't know
which car I get finita Asian bears don't
give a [ __ ] about how successful you
think you are you still that [ __ ] mom I
have money now no you have an attitude
god dammit but it was definitely cool
seeing my mom and dad come here versus
me going to them it was something that
hasn't happened before
and you best believe the reason why I'm
weird it's because of them not me
growing up in a very strict Asian family
you guys already know that I butt heads
with my parents a lot I mean all of us
do but I think as you get older you
start to realize less of the things that
make you different from your parents but
more the things that make you similar
but one of the things I didn't pick up
on my mom is her sneaky snake nish a
woman's a damn crook I genuinely think
that almost every conversation that I
have with my mom is about how much money
she's gonna take from me when she
retires her not for me I don't really
mind giving my mom money I'll give her
as much as she wants but it's not about
that it's about the way that she says it
for example she could say honey you're
doing so well you have a lot of money so
you're gonna help mom out when she
retires right but how she says it
I raised a your fed asset for too long
you better give me money or you die and
with that attitude even Jesus don't want
to give you his blessing [ __ ] but - my
mom's positive side she's not really
materialistic she doesn't want like
Gucci this Louie that proud of that but
either way she's still had a capitalize
on taking
away from me as much as she want which I
was more than happy to give so where did
we go the Korean market and like I said
before my mom's not that bougie type of
woman so of course she wanted to get as
much things as she wanted from the
supermarket but damn how much kimchi do
you need you know what the worst part
about this experience was wasn't based
on the fact that my mom wanted to buy a
lot of [ __ ] was the fact that there was
older women there that was making my mom
buy extra [ __ ] this lady trying to take
all my money selling my mama stuff that
she don't need if you guys don't know
when you go to a Korean market
especially in LA there's always these IG
box on the side trying to sell you [ __ ]
as if you don't buy it
you're gonna die the next day and it's
not like Costco where you got like this
sweet Mexican white or black lady that
wants to sell you like a cup of crackers
for a few dollars yeah baby you should
try this now it's kind of more like you
buy this one oh ah because apparently
everything at a Korean store is always
on sale
yeah really what do you sell on regular
price then you line [ __ ] crooks oh
the moment she heard things were on sale
she's like i'ma buy everything really
how much dry fish octopus balls and dead
kelp do you need woman but all joking
aside it was super fun whatever my mom
needs I'm more than happy to give it to
him it was just um it's the way that she
said but I don't know for a lot of you
guys out there this really isn't that
big of a deal but for me it is I mean I
was I wanted to be a stand-up comedian
and you have to realize that becoming a
very famous and popular comedian it
doesn't happen overnight so I was
planning to be broken poor for a very
long time not being able to give my
parents [ __ ] so even for me to be able
to go out and buy my parents groceries
with me mmm that's that's huge for me
and you know it's kind of a pleasure to
be able to like go into a store and my
mom's like I want this and I'm like dude
imma buy that for you easy so for me if
I ask her this simple question and she
says this Cuban toy you wouldn't do a
half that's all I need
so fear me damn about the guy see baby
running a beauty supply store back at
home for the past 26 years now and you
guys know when you own your own personal
business your own person your own own
personal bit [ __ ]